hello everyone so today we're gonna talk
about Zika virus we're going to talk
about mosquitoes we're going to talk
about pregnancy but we're also going to
focus on what you the high school
student can do and should be doing to
protect yourself from mosquito bites so
I want to start today and talk about the
World Health Organization and you'll see
that
waho stands for the World Health
Organization and the World Health
Organization announced on the 1st of
February this year a public health
emergency of international concern we've
only ever had four and this was the
fourth our first one was in April 2009
when we had pandemic influenza or
pandemic flu in May of 2014 we had
another emergency for polio then in
August of 2014 we had an emergency for a
bowler and I had three trips to West
Africa setting up Ebola hospitals and
treating Ebola patients and then on the
first of February this year in 2016 we
had another public health emergency and
this wasn't because of the mosquitoes
this wasn't related to the virus this
was because in Brazil they were seeing
babies born with what's called
microcephaly or their heads were much
smaller than they should be and then
something amazing happened because when
this announcement when this announcement
this emergency happened on the 1st of
February we didn't know a lot about the
zika virus we didn't know about a lot
about the zika virus and the effects it
would have on pregnant women let alone
the effect it would have on unborn
babies and on April 13th only a few
weeks ago this year a new study was
published by colleagues of mine from the
Center for Disease Control in Atlanta
Georgia and here's a copy of this paper
that's freely available on the internet
for you to read and they published the
first evidence that Zika virus was
related to birth defects and how it
affected pregnant women so we now know
today we now know that the Zika virus
infects can infect pregnant women and
can somehow get into
those babies and cause birth defects and
that book the main birth defect we're
seeing is called microcephaly and this
side slide I want to show you what a
typical head size of a baby looks like
and a baby with microcephaly has a head
size that's smaller than normal and a
baby with severe microcephaly has a much
very much smaller head size now why do
they have smaller head sizes because we
now know that the Zika virus attacks the
brain and the the Zika virus affects the
growth and development of the brain and
when Europe and babies fetuses that are
in the mother in the womb before they're
born as the brain grows the head grows
now if you have a virus like Zika that
attacks the brain the head doesn't grow
as fast and that's why we're getting
babies born with smaller head sizes but
we're also seeing other problems at the
moment we're also seeing babies that are
born and in these very newborn babies
these young infants we're seeing
problems with their eyes with their
sight we're hearing the same problems
with their hearing we're seeing problems
with their growth and development and so
there's still a lot we need to learn
about the effects of Zika virus and the
effects of that has on pregnant women
and on fetuses and on newborn babies and
the way that we measure this is we take
a tape measure when the baby's born so
we wait up 24 hours after the baby's
born and we put a tape measure around
their head and we measured the size of
their head but it's really important
that when we worked with the nurses with
the doctors with the community health
workers around the world that I work
with that they all take the same
measurement so we're doing lots of
courses and lots of training at the
moment to teach nurses and doctors and
community health workers how to take
this measurement and we can see that by
putting a tape measure around the head
whether the head is normal or ass below
normal and then we'll repeat this every
week and we'll repeat this for a number
of years to look at the development of
the baby and this is really important
another way that we can diagnose what's
called microcephaly before the baby's
born is by taking ultrasounds now the
the emergency we have so far is so
large that we don't have time to go and
teach everyone in the world how to read
these ultrasounds so what we do we get
them to take an ultrasound of the
pregnant woman and then we use
telemedicine like we're doing today the
same video conferencing software that
you're using today we use for them to
show us what the ultrasound of the
pregnant woman's baby looks like and
then we get other physicians and nurses
who are much better too much more
experts in the field of ultrasound and
they help them diagnose whether the baby
has a small head since that emergencies
been announced the first of February on
TV a number of times I've been on scene
in I've been on the BBC I've been on
Canada CTV and I've been on al-jazeera
and the challenge that I've faced as a
public health expert is that like this
one here on al-jazeera Zika virus fears
but more Americans test positive after
traveling what I want to tell you today
there's nothing to be scared about and
we have to ensure that people are
educated they're aware and they
understand what the Zika virus is how
it's transmitted by mosquitoes how do we
protect ourselves and what we need to do
to decrease that risk and it's so
important that we're not scared about
this but we're actually we take action
and we do the right thing to protect us
from being bitten by mosquitoes and
here's a map of Brazil and this is where
it all started about May 2015 we've
known about the Zika virus since 1947 it
comes from a very beautiful forest in
the country of Uganda in Africa and it
really hasn't been related to causing
birth defects in babies for many until
very recently about 12 months ago and it
started in Brazil and here in Brazil you
can see the red dots and the red dots
show where these babies that have been
born with small heads actually started
being reported in 2015 and that's why
the World Health Organization in
February of this year announced an
emergency and what we've seen very
rapidly very quickly the spread of the
Zika virus not
as we've seen it before in Africa and
Asia but when it appeared in Brazil it
spread all through other countries in
this in South America it went to Central
America it went to the Caribbean it's
now in the Pacific Islands it's been
there before but it's gone back there
now it's in Hawaii for example we've had
people that have traveled to some moyen
people have traveled to Brazil and come
back to why we don't see local
transmission so it's not in the mosquito
population but it's starting to appear
in many countries throughout the world
and we're at nearly 60 countries right
now where the mosquitoes are
transmitting Zika virus but not here in
the United States the cases that we've
had here in the United States have just
been from people traveling to any of
these countries here that are colored in
blue so if we look at the information
that we have today here in the United
States the Center for Disease Control
Atlanta tells us that we have at
laboratory-confirmed these are people
that have been sick gone to a doctor had
a blood sample and that blood samples
been sent to a laboratory and have
tested positive for the Zika virus
we have 388 cases some of those have
been in pregnant women all of those
cases all of the 388 have traveled
outside the US to countries with known
Zika virus in the US territories is a
little bit different the story is a
little bit different we've had 503 known
laboratory confirmed cases America Samoa
Puerto Rico and the US Virgin Islands
now those three countries are different
because the virus is now in their
mosquito populations and it's possible
if you live in Puerto Rico the US Virgin
Islands or American Samoa
if you're bitten by a mosquito you may
be able to get the Zika virus and we're
really concerned about two types of
mosquitoes and these two types of
mosquitoes are really easy to identify
the first one is the ATS a Dai
mosquito and it really is it's not
native here in the US it actually came
from Africa but it has been it does live
here now in the US and we sometimes call
this the yellow fever mosquito
the other mosquito we're worried about
is the ad DS elbow pictus which comes
from Asia and it now lives here in the
United States and we call that the Asian
tiger mosquito and these mosquitoes in
your backyard in your home where you
live are really easy to identify have a
look closely at these two photos can you
see their legs can you see the white
stripes
Aedes species of mosquitoes have white
stripes on their legs so if you're at
your house at your home and you see
those mosquitoes and they don't have any
stripes then they're not the Aedes type
but if they do have white stripes then
they belong to a TS species of mosquito
and near the mosquitoes were worried
about and the Center for Disease Control
the CDC in Atlanta Georgia has produced
two maps and here's the first map on the
left is the ADEs a JIP died that first
mosquito we looked at and these are the
states in the middle of summer where
these mosquitoes have been found in
previous years the Aedes albopictus
mosquito is shown on the map on the
right hand side and you can see the
states where they we know they live but
that doesn't show us the risk and what
it shows us here is that there's going
to be about 30 states in the US this
year that are gonna have the right
mosquitoes to spread the virus but they
may not spread the virus and I'm gonna
show you why so first of all let's look
up and talk about a little bit about
risk if we go back to this these these
maps that are on the CDC website it
doesn't really tell us is the mosquito
in my backyard does it live because the
mosquito doesn't live at high altitudes
it lives at altitudes down where it's
warm it's hot and it's right it's wet
and it doesn't live it that that that
air is were above 6500 feet and it's not
shown on this map a study that came out
two days ago by NASA actually took all
the information we've had from previous
years and started to generate maps based
on risk by month and let's look here the
Aedes aegypti mosquito and we know in
winter it's cold
the mosquitos not around but we know
that in May June July August and
September can you see those dots the red
the orange dot is high that yellow dot
is low-risk and it shows where these
mosquitoes have been found and where
we're going to see risk but it doesn't
take us down to our local level and
what's really interesting is that even
though we may have the mosquito present
it doesn't mean it's going to transmit
the virus and this is why because in the
US the only way the mosquito can get
infected is if the mosquito bites
someone that already has the infection
and that's a really important message to
understand you've got to understand that
- for the mosquito to get infected it
has to bite someone that has the
infection and they have their virus in
the blood and we all know that
mosquitoes when they bite us they suck
in blood these mosquitos they eat is a
Diane Davies albopictus can also
transmit other viruses and you may have
heard of diseases like yellow fever we
give a vaccination for that you may have
heard of diseases like dengue there's
been a dengue outbreak for the last six
months in Hawaii you may have heard of
diseases like Chuck Agana which is a new
disease for the last couple of years and
again that's present their spread by the
same mosquito Zika is spread by these
mosquitoes and so this mosquito has to
bite someone is infected before it can
transmit the virus to someone else and
this is how it does it the mosquito
bites a person with the infection these
mosquitos mainly bite in the day so if
you we were really looking for
mosquitoes that bite in the day but
don't be fooled by that these mosquitoes
can also buy it at night we get these
mosquitoes here in Washington DC and I
know last year I got bitten when I was
out having a barbecue with my family we
get bitten even when it's dark so
they're not just daytime biters when
they bite you they suck in the blood
that takes in the virus the Zika virus
it goes down to their stomach their gut
it then enters their bloodstream this
circuitry system and it goes back up to
their saliva glands which is in their
mouth part their prospect proboscis
then when they take their next bite when
they inject saliva that's where the
virus is this cycle in the mosquito
takes about ten days so even if a
mosquito bites an infected person it's
about ten days before that mosquito can
transmit the virus but which of these
mosquitoes actually bite guess what the
male's don't bite the boy mosquitoes
don't bite it's the female mosquitoes
the female mosquitoes are the ones that
bite us and it's really important now
that what we're doing in communities and
I've been doing a lot of work with with
high schools in South America and
Central America and even here in the
u.s. in states like Georgia Alabama and
Tennessee in Florida
we're getting students now to actually
help us identify where these mosquitoes
with white bands on their legs are
actually there are they in your
neighborhood and the reason we're doing
this is we know that these mosquitoes
don't fly very far they fly about the
length of a football field about 150
feet so if you find mosquitoes with
white legs in your backyard
they fly about the length of the
football field and then they'll come
back in the evening and they really stay
locally and so we can control these
mosquitoes locally then we can decrease
the risk of Zika virus this slide here
shows what's what's what's been
happening a lot in medicine public
health hospitals are being using this
for years we produce what's called
infographics and this is an infographic
produced by the CDC which focuses on not
just Zika but chikungunya and dengue and
here it is here this infographic is
explaining what local transmission
remember we we talked about the
mosquitoes in Puerto Rico American Samoa
the US Virgin Islands local transmission
is occurring in those three countries
local transmissions not occurring in the
US 48 states also Hawaii and Alaska so
here where local transmission you've got
understand this term it's where a
mosquito bites a person who's infected
again we know it takes about ten days
for the virus to go through the mosquito
then the mascara then bites someone
who's healthy and they inject the virus
in the saliva
now within three to seven days that
person may become sick but we know with
Zika virus not everyone's going to
become sick only some people will what
we're having here in the United States
right now is what's caught an imported
case of Zika and these important cases
where someone goes on for a business
trip goes on vacation down to those
countries I showed you on the map that
are blue they get bitten by a mosquito
that has the Zika virus within three to
seven days they may feel sick some won't
feel sick and they come back to the US
and we diagnose them through a
laboratory test that they have the virus
and that's called that's an imported
case and that's what we're seeing now in
the United States what we're concerned
about is getting local transmission as
we get more of these mosquitoes in
spring and some / summer and the
potential for getting more people
infected with the Zika virus leading to
local transmission and when we talk
about people getting sick from the Zika
virus they really have four symptoms
that we're going to focus on they get a
fever they get a rash they could have
joint pain but not always they could
have red eyes which we call
conjunctivitis and it's very similar to
these other diseases that are
transmitted by mosquitos called dengue
and chikungunya what makes these three
diseases unique here in the United
States is these are nationally
notifiable diseases or nationally
notifiable conditions so that if you're
sick and you go to see your physician
your doctor or a nurse and they test you
and that test comes back positive by law
by legislation they have to report this
disease to the local County Health
Department who then reports them to the
State Health Department who then reports
it to the Center for Disease Control in
Atlanta and that's what we mean by
nationally notifiable diseases and I've
just recently come back from South
America I went to five countries I saw a
lot of people that were sick and I can
tell you now that not everyone had all
these four symptoms
nearly everyone had fever but not
everyone had
nilly everyone had fever and some had
red eyes or conjunctivitis but not
everyone so this is still a very
challenging disease for us to diagnose
when you look at what what do we do how
do we protect ourselves now you could be
sick with Zika you could be sick with
chikungunya you could be sick with
dengue but it's really important that we
have to take responsibility for
ourselves and protect ourselves and it's
really important that if we have these
symptoms that over that seven-day period
where we may be able to transmit the
virus to mosquitoes we have to prevent
ourselves from being bitten by
mosquitoes and the ways that we can do
that well we know that daytime is the
most likely time for these mosquitoes to
buy these mosquitoes with white bands on
their legs
most likely bite in the daytime
especially when the Sun comes up indoor
at dawn and when the Sun Goes Down at
dusk but remember they it still always
the case they can bite at nighttime so
we've got to protect ourselves we might
want to protect ourselves with clothing
socks lawn para trousers shirts long
shirts from being bitten we want to use
insect repellent and so one of the
questions that I get asked I teach at
both Harvard University and Penn State
University when all our students were
going on spring break one of the
questions that all the students asked me
was hey we're going on spring break do
we put our sunscreen on first or our
insect repellent on first that's a
really good question and you put the
sunscreen on first and then you put the
insect repellent on second and not many
people know that but that's the way you
do it again we can wear protective
clothing but we can also what we can do
as individuals within our families we
can mosquito-proof our homes we can
decrease the likelihood of the
mosquitoes laying their eggs reproducing
around our homes and we can decrease the
risk of being bitten by a mosquito so
what the Center for Disease Control New
York has done this Florida's done this
Alabama California Louisiana Hawaii's
doing this they're putting together Zika
prevention kits and the work that I've
been doing in high schools is actually
helping them raise some money
we know that we can put these kids
together they have a bed net they have
these little larvacide tablets where you
can put them in water and it kills the
that mosquito larvae we have some DEET
or some some some insect repellent that
it that is known to work and there's a
list of those that we can provide we use
permethrin spray on our clothes we don't
put that on our skin we put that on our
clothes we know that we can take our
temperature in case we have a fever we
now know that Zika can be transmitted in
transmitted sexually from the mantle
through semen so we can provide condoms
and it's really interesting that high
school students that I've been working
with have been putting through these
kits and selling them to people in their
community one to raise the awareness of
mosquitoes and the potential getting
Zika but also to make some money and I
had some students knock on my door
in Washington DC just recently and that
was selling these at $20 each and I
thought what a great idea that that was
did I need it no but did I pay them the
$20 I sure did because I really like
their initiative and we started doing
this in the countries I went to in South
America and the nice thing is is that
the Center for Disease Control has
actually made this really easy for you
you make this kit you put it in a bag
you sell it for twenty dollars and they
even they've even printed information
that you can copy from the bit from
download from the website print it out
and hand out to the families that you
sell the kids to and it tells them how
to use the kit so all the information
you need is there and and again um I
have two children they're both in middle
school and this is what they're going to
do in their summer break focus on
selling Zika kits so let's look at the
mosquito lifecycle and this is really
important to understand the the risks of
transmission of Zika we know it's not
the male mosquito it's the female
mosquito that bites us so we only get
bitten by female mosquitoes they lay
eggs in water and then what's really
remarkable about these Aedes mosquitoes
that they can lay their eggs in a very
small amount of water and the eggs can
either some hatch or they can survive
for many many months and we know here in
Washington DC that we have mosquitoes
that lay their eggs they survive the
winter
they survived the snow and they're still
there in the spring in the summer and
they hatch out usually these eggs though
they had CEO in a few days
sorry in a few days to a few months and
they produce what's called larvae
those lava within five days turn into a
pupa
and those pupae then live in the water
and their development the young flying
mosquitoes in two to three days it then
takes a few weeks for those mosquitoes
those those flying mosquitoes then to
mature where they can actually transmit
the virus but if you understand the
mosquito lifecycle then you also
understand the second opportunity I want
to give high school students and things
that you can do and one of those is you
can do is help the local County Health
Department or the local mosquito vector
control program in identifying where
there are eggs whether a larvae where
there are pupae whether a young adult
mosquitoes hatching in water and where
there's actually mosquitoes with white
bands on their legs actually biting
people and you can see the five photos
here show you those life cycles and so
what we've done through our community
engagement through using high school
students we've actually started programs
where they can go out and help the
community and it's really important
because we know how to control
mosquitoes we're just not really good at
it
because we don't take we don't pay much
attention but this year we've really got
to focus on how to control the mask is
because we have this risk of this of
this Zika virus and we know that pop
plants can have water we know that there
are swimming pools we know there are
areas that are like car tires that
contain water where the mosquitoes can
breed we know that if there we see any
water we have to drain it out and tip it
out and get rid of it we know that we
put flowers and visors over very short
period of time
mosquitoes could lay their eggs there we
know that any barrels containers buckets
that we have in the backyard or the
front yard that have water we have to
put a lid on top of them and we also
know that we have to protect our homes
whether we've got air conditioning or we
don't have air conditioning how do we
put in sin insect screens on the wall on
the windows on the doors and keep them
closed to ensure that the mosquitoes
don't come inside
so here in the US at every county at
every city in every town
there are mosquito surveillance programs
ongoing right now and they could really
use your help and from the five
countries I went to in South America
they had mosquito surveillance programs
and we engaged the students from the
high schools down there to actually help
those programs and what these mosquitos
about surveillance programs do they
estimate the number of mosquitoes the
mosquito abundance in the area
remember these means mosquitoes only fly
150 feet or about the length of a
football field from where they actually
breed so they don't fly miles we use the
estimates by Counting the mosquitoes in
their lifecycle eggs pupae larvae and
adults and we indicate this levels of
risk at the local neighborhood level and
then we do this maybe every day every
week so we can compare the results over
time and location we put them on maps so
again you could take a real important
role yourself in your community in that
we land where you live by helping your
local county health department or your
local mosquito vector control program by
doing larval and pupil surveys by this
little traps that we can buy and we can
get the trap at catch eggs and we also
get sticky traps that catch mosquito
adult mosquitoes and we can identify do
they have white bands on their legs and
if they do we report them and what do we
do with that information well we we've
had mosquito diseases that have been
transmitted by mosquitoes we've had them
for years here in the US we had West
Nile virus and here's a map of New York
we're not just the government but also
the schools in New York helped set out
some traps and help set in information
every day and the way they did that they
use their cell phone so I'm going to
show you how we use cell phones to send
in then it that critical that really
important information that's needed and
this is a map of New York's New York
which showed where the traps that were
laid out for West Nile virus and they
took all that information every day and
they produced these heat maps and these
maps here are risk maps and you can see
the darker the color the higher the
concentration of the high the number of
mosquitoes so therefore the high-risk
and places like New York City New York
State places like Florida Georgia
Alabama California Hawaii are producing
these maps every day to show us the risk
so again you could participate and help
identify mosquitoes on a daily basis and
then call into the County Health
Department and let them know the results
of what you find the other project the
third project we set up in South America
with high school students was that we
know how to kill mosquitoes we use
insecticides but the big problem we have
that sometimes over time when we use the
same insecticide over and over again we
get what's called resistance and
mosquitoes who develop resistance don't
die that well from using the
insecticides so one of the projects we
set up was with students was taking a
glass jar capturing mosquitoes you you
put the insecticide around the glass jar
catch the mosquitoes and you're leaving
there for an hour and you then you count
how many of those mosquitoes died and if
they die then we show that the mosquito
insecticide is working if they didn't
die then we've got to call the county
health department say hey look at this
mosquitoes didn't die and we've got to
work out why and it's information we can
find it doesn't cost much money to get a
glass jar and conduct these experiments
oh it's a really good science experiment
the Center for Disease Control has
actually published the protocols the
procedures of how to set up these
experiments and this is a picture taken
from the manual that's available on the
website available online to do this and
I want to give you a real world example
now this is Orange County in California
this is their vector control program and
taken from their website this morning
they have a big sign up we need your
help and they want every citizen they
want every person throughout the whole
neighborhood throughout the community to
report that if they get bitten or they
see mosquitoes biting you in the daytime
to ring this number and that's a really
good idea and we're seeing counties and
towns and cities throughout the country
do this and sup these programs but the
thing is high school students
a lot of you have these the phones so
why do we why do we want to make a phone
call why don't we use an app why don't
we send a text message
why don't we use social media why don't
we use Facebook or Twitter or what's
happened and this is really important
for it for Ebola disease for the nurses
to communicate we used whatsapp what
we've set up now for students is an
actual using an app to actually report
so you don't actually have to make a
phone call and talk to a person you
could actually just record it on your
phone like a text message and send it in
to their to their surveillance system
and this is what we've got and so the
app that you can download you can put on
your phones look something like this and
I'll have your name has your address has
your phone number tells you well my
property or my house are there dogs on
the property cuz that's really important
when the when the mosquito control
people come out they want to know
whether there's dogs on around in your
in your in your yard so they don't get
bitten where did you see the mosquito or
we saw it around the oak trees maybe you
might have got a photo of it if you got
a photo of it you can send the photo on
the app and it's really important that
we know the location of where you are
when you send in your report and many of
us don't have to try very hard to send
in the location because this is really
cool app and I want you to Google this
so whenever I give homework to my to my
son and my daughter or in middle school
and I try to tell them let's do you how
much they owe dad can't we just Boogle
it and so what you can do if you can
Google what three words and what three
words is on the website as it has a
website it also has an app what three
words has taken the world and has
divided the world up into squares that a
nine feet by nine feet and they've put
three words for every square now to
cover the whole globe it takes 57
trillion squares so they have taken 57
trillion squares 9 feet by 9 feet giving
them a three word identification and you
can now use their app to identify where
you are when you see a mosquito or when
you see an egg or when you see pupae or
larvae or something else you want to
report if you sent me those three words
to my phone
I would then be able to identify exactly
where you are where your square is 9
feet by 9 feet and we use this all the
time it's a really easy way for us to
put information on a map and it's called
what three words
so in Orange County this is what they're
doing as people either call in
information or send in information every
day they're making maps and this is one
of the maps and as you can see the red
areas is where this ATS a gypto
mosquitoes being found and the yellow
areas is where ATS albopictus mosquitos
being found and they put this on the
internet on the website so that every
person in the community can check this
website and they know where the
mosquitoes have been found the previous
day so I've given you a couple of
projects that high school students can
do if you know a couple of ways that you
can make some money over the summer I
just want to talk about there are lots
of things that we know but there's still
many more things that we don't know
about this Zika virus and we're learning
every day so just to summarize what we
know Zika can be spread from a pregnant
woman to her unborn baby the fetus
during pregnancy we know that we now
know as of April 13 this is only very
new scientific information that the
infection in pregnancy can be linked to
birth defects but there's still a lot to
learn about that we know that the Zika
spurt is spread mostly by the bite of an
infected Aedes species Mascara these are
these mosquitoes with white bands on
their legs and even though these
mosquitoes mainly bite in the day they
can also bite at nighttime we also know
today that the Zika virus is not locally
transmitted by mosquitoes in the u.s. 48
continental States it's not in Alaska
it's not in Hawaii either but we do know
those mosquitoes are found here and
because there's most mosquitoes that
spread sweet zika or pants fitzek are
found through many countries throughout
the world
we're going to see many more countries
experience Zika outbreaks the last thing
that we know is that there is no vaccine
for Zika and there's no medicine or
treatment for Zika
we have to treat the symptoms we there
is that there's no actual cure for Zika
and that's really important to
understand a couple of things that we
don't know and that will research from
that scientists are working on right now
today when is there a safe time during
the nine months of pregnancy to travel
to an area with Zika when is there a
safe time when you might be infected
with Zika over your nine month of
pregnancy we don't know if you do travel
to an area where there's local Zeke of
transmission and you're bitten we don't
know how likely you are to get Zika we
can't tell you that we just don't know
and we don't also don't know that if
you're female and you're pregnant and
you get bitten we don't know how likely
your baby is to have birth defects we
have seen birth defects we're very
concerned about them but we don't know
how likely you are to get birth that
your baby to have but the birth defects
if you're infected by the Zika virus and
this is really important so when I went
to five countries in South America to
help hospitals to help patients to help
the doctors and the nurses and I worked
with high school students we came up
with some programs and it's really an
easy because we have phones we have the
internet we have ways of communication
so for all of us it's easier than ever
right now for us to communicate
collaborate connect and it's essential
for us as citizens in here in the United
States to actually help our government
to help our local health department to
help our local mosquito control program
to provide them information that they
don't have the resources to get on a day
to day basis and we can do that really
easily so thank you everyone for
listening
so do we have any questions or comments
for dr. McGregor Skinner
who can ask we have a question whose ass
we have a question who's gonna ask the
question question in the back can you
stand up so I can know who can do it
top right there the mic is here if you
want to see look at the camera all right
is there more likely for people to get
bit by a mosquito
light like how could I put this like is
it like we have Los Angeles for people
to get bit by mosquitoes that's a really
good question because only a few years
ago these types of mosquitoes weren't
really found in California but they have
been recently and they have been when we
had the West Nile virus outbreak so we
now know and we call in California we
call these invasive species of
mosquitoes and so it's really important
like in Orange County in LA and
everywhere else that we actually get
together as a community and we try to
help the local County Health Department
and the mosquito program to actually
identify where these types of Aedes
mosquitoes the ones with the white bands
are actually where they are because we
really don't know and we need to get all
that you need to give as much adventure
so we can now when you have these
mosquitoes the mosquito doesn't doesn't
pick who they want to bite they just
bite us they'll bite anyone
and then what's releasing these
mosquitoes only bite people and it's so
that no matter if we're outside and the
mosquitoes in the area they're going to
find us and when they find us they're
going to try to bite us especially
during the tape daytime so it's really
important for this spring in this summer
that we first of all we identify where
the mosquitoes aren't if they always try
to prevent them from from from from
breeding and from being where they are
so we we try to control them we need to
prevent them from from laying their eggs
and for those eggs as I showed you the
life cycle from going through that life
cycle but if we do find if we find adult
mosquitoes with white bands on their
legs one of the really cool things we
can do is set up a program to help the
cow
Health Department like Orange County's
doing to actually report and it's called
like citizen reporting we could report
every day that whether we did or did not
find mosquitoes around our house and
that's really important because we know
that if the mosquitoes are there we go
outside they'll find us really easy and
they're gonna want to bite because they
need to bite us to get that blood we
have another question well you said that
mosquitoes only bite humans but in one
of your slides you were like make sure
there's not a dog outside what would
happen if the dog is gonna attack the
person who may be coming to look at the
mosquito oh I wondered that too so they
don't bite animals they only bite humans
evolve over time with people and
wherever we've moved that mosquitoes
follow us so this is a mosquito that has
evolved to live with us the Aedes
albopictus is very similar but it it is
a little different it does bite animals
it will boy it will bite our dog it will
bite our pet cat but we don't know what
the role or whether it were there's any
role at all his Zika virus can affect
our dogs and cat we don't know that and
we don't know whether the weather the
Zika virus actually had can be
transmitted from a dog to a Misco we
don't know that and it's highly unlikely
what we're really concerned about is the
mosquito biting an infected person a
person with Zika virus in their blood
and then being able to transmit that
virus to someone who doesn't have the
Zika virus and so we're really worried
about the mosquitos biting people at
this stage and we're really worried
about the numbers of mosquitoes we're
going to get over summer and we're gonna
get a lot and that's what we're
concerned about why do I do yeah I wanna
know if there's any food is there any
food that we can eat to prevent
mosquitoes from biting us well that's a
great question there's that there's been
a lot of discussion about this there
hasn't been a lot proven about it again
it's like you know had he keeps on these
aways that you all put garlic around our
neck so I'm not really sure
I know some people say off you take
certain vitamins that might be this
wheat that's not something we recommend
but what we do recommend is that if
you're outside wear long sleeve shirts
wear trousers don't because this these
particular mosquitoes they like to bite
you on the ankle and if you get this is
this one out there though they'll find
you and they'll try to bite you on the
ankle it's really important on any area
that you have exposed use approved
insect repellent follow the directions
on the back of the insect repellent on
your clothes
use that permethrin spray that's part of
your Zika prevention pack put that in
your pack these are this is how you're
going to make money over summer holidays
trust me you really will and it's really
important that at night we try to keep
the windows closed if we have air
conditioned we turn it on turn on if we
don't keep the windows open but make
sure we have screens on the doors
because what happens is when this
mosquito bites us they can't fly verify
they can fly about three feet because
why they're big and fat they're full of
blood and what they have to do then is
sit on a vertical surface for about 30
minutes to allow the water and the
protein from the blood to separate and
so that's why when you wake up in the
morning you might see mosquitoes on the
roof on the walls and they don't fly
very fast they're really easy to kill
because they're full of blood and so it
all happens locally this is really
important to prevent mosquitoes we have
to take these actions at I outlined
around our house and that's really
important to do so how much blood do you
think not very much have you ever been
bitten by mosquito yeah did they take
much blood yes they did
no they don't take they don't take a lot
of blood but they need that blood
because they take they need that protein
that's their food that's what they need
and they need that protein because for
the female it's only the female bathroom
it's only the female mosquitoes the
biters they need that protein before
they can lay their eggs so it's really
important there are many ways we can
break the lifecycle so yes do I think
I'm gonna get bitten by a mosquito in
Washington DC this year of course I am
I get bitten every summer I can't avoid
it what I can't avoid if there's anyone
in my neighborhood if there's anyone
my street that may have had Zika they
need to stay inside for at least seven
days and not get bitten they need to
tell us so that we know that we have to
be more vigilant we have to do a bit
more proactive we have to take certain
actions we have to increase and
strengthen what we need to do and we
have to ensure that you know even though
we enjoy the outdoors use the insect
repellent wear the proper clothes you
spray your clothes with permethrin
ensure that you don't get bitten if you
decrease that risk then you decrease the
likelihood of the Zika being transmitted
and you decrease your personal risk this
is all about you you decrease your
individual risk from being get getting
the Zika virus I have a question why do
you think cases of microcephaly only
started appearing in 2015
even though Zika was first discovered in
1947 that's a great question and this is
we've been discussing this now in the
meetings I'm on the World Health
Organization Zika risk communication
team we meet twice a week and we're
having these discussions all the time we
thought it might have been environmental
toxins we thought it might have been
related to maybe other problems like you
know we've seen microcephaly before we
see microcephaly in in mums that have
don't have good nutrition you know
severe severe malnutrition can lead to
microcephaly we've seen III saw three
babies just recently in teenage mums who
had and the baby's head microcephaly and
the mums had been drinking out the
halters throughout their pregnancy so we
know alcohol and drug abuse can lead to
microcephaly and so when we first saw
microcephaly in Brazil we didn't really
believe that a virus transmitted by a
mosquito could actually do this so why
when we had the hips on this hand we had
Zika virus this over over here we had
microcephaly these small heads and
babies and we didn't know there was a
relationship and it's only recently that
we've actually found that the virus can
get into people get into these pregnant
mums and actually can be can go from the
blood through the placenta into the baby
and we've seen now evidence the Zika
virus has been in these babies and it
attacks the brain and that there's still
a lot of question to it to answer why is
this not happening in a hundred percent
of all the mum
and all their babies it's not it's
happening in a very small percentage
what makes these small percentage of the
mums that are having babies with
microcephaly what makes them different
at the moment we don't really know I was
wondering how exactly that the virus get
its name
oh it comes from a really beautiful
forest in Uganda and I've been there so
if you go to Uganda Uganda is a country
in Africa there's a forest called the
Zika forest now this virus lives in
monkeys and so we know the virus lives
in the monkeys in the Zika forest and we
believe that the mosquitoes have have
been had bitten
now they they they they took a blood
meal they they they they bit that the
monkeys took blood from the monkeys and
the mosquitos got infected and we've
known if this happened in 1947 where the
first
people got infected by Zika and it
actually came from the Zika forest in
Uganda but these mosquitoes are so good
at travel they can travel on planes they
can travel on ships and they these
mosquitoes especially Egypt I has really
evolved to live with us it loves car
tires
it loves breeding and laying its eggs
inside car tires and this car tires all
over our community it loves laying in
eggs in buckets of water
it loves laying their eggs in bird baths
and so where there's little bits of
water these mosquitoes have adapted to
lay their eggs in very tiny amounts of
water and those eggs survive and hatch
and so it's really important it came
from Africa we believe it hasn't caused
any problems but it went to Asia
we saw outbreaks in Asia it didn't cause
microcephaly it's only recently that
we're now seeing these birth defects and
babies so again this is an area of
research that both here at the National
Institutes of Health and the CDC are
really actively involved in another
question is there any progress in
finding a cure for Sita yes that's a
really really good question and again a
lot of the times when I deal with public
health emergencies like Ebola now we're
dealing with Zika the first thing that
our our government our politicians ask
us do we have a vaccine and we didn't
have a vaccine
rebola and right now we don't have a
vaccine for Zika but there's a lot of
clever scientists out there that are
doing studies right now trying to
develop a vaccine but when we develop a
vaccine we have to ensure that it's safe
and that takes a series of trials we
call these clinical trials and it takes
time so even now with the science that
we have we can develop a vaccine but
it's not going to be commercially
available it's not going to be available
for you and I to take for a number of
years because that's the process that's
the cycle we have to take through these
trials to ensure it's safe and it
doesn't do more harm than good so yes we
have the science we have the ability to
develop a vaccine it's just gonna be a
few years before we had that vaccine
available for us we have a question in
LA ok why did why is it that the female
mosquito bites and not the male mosquito
that's a great question just because she
needs the blood for to lay her eggs and
she takes the protein out of the blood
and so she needs that meal the mosquito
member the man with scooter doesn't need
that cuz he doesn't lay the eggs so what
happens that all mosquitoes and there's
about 3,500 species of mosquito
throughout the world there's about 300
of these species of mosquito actually
transmitted diseases to people in this
particular case we're really concerned
about these Aedes species mosquitoes and
again it's the same across with all
mosquitoes it's the females that need to
take the blood to get the protein from
the blood so that they again go and lay
their eggs and that's what they need and
so that's why the female mosquito bites
and the thing is about these Aedes
especially they're either gypto mosquito
and it's evolved with people it's a
really aggressive biter it doesn't just
bite you it'll bite the person next to
you it then bites the person next to you
it will bite multiple people on the same
day you won't just bite one person it
could bite many people in the same day
if they're in the same backyard the same
front yard the same local vicinity so
they they will just keep biting and keep
taking blood meals even in the same day
question oh sorry it's okay if you have
Zika virus during your teens is there
going to affect your pregnancy in the
future that's a really good question and
we at this stage we believe it's it does
it because what we're finding is that
people who have the Zika virus are sick
for no more than seven days and after
seven days we've found that the actual
virus is no longer found in the blood
and so we believe right now with the
evidence we have right now that there's
no long-lasting effect from Zika virus
unless you're pregnant and you get
bitten and infected while you're
pregnant
then we're concerned but for if you and
right now I just had a phone call from a
school in Chicago and they said hey
we're going down to South to South
America for our school trip should we
leave all the girls behind and not take
them no you shouldn't do that
again you've got to go and enjoy your
school trip don't cancel it you don't
enjoy the school trip but ensure that
you're protected and you follow that
what the recommendations protect
yourself from being bitten if you get
sick we know and we this is what we
believe right now there is no long-term
lasting effect again they're still we're
still researching this we're still
asking the same questions and many
doctors and nurses and scientists are us
in the question so it's really important
we understand but at this stage we're
saying no there's no long-term lasting
effects of it that's a really good
question what we have found which is
really amazing is that we have found
that the virus in men even though it's
not found in their blood the virus can
be found in their semen and so what
we're recommending now if a man gets
infected he shouldn't have sex or he if
he has sex he who has to use a condom
for at least six months and that's the
recommendation for the Center for
Disease Control right now it may change
as we learn more
okay my question was what are the like
effect the fatality rates of babies who
are infected with Zika that's a really
good question and and we know that we
have about about we have in the United
States every year about 4 million babies
are born every year we know that even
before Zika but there's about 2,500 of
those babies that have microcephaly we
have many years of information many
years of data that shows that about
2,500 out about 4 million babies born
every year many of those babies go on
and and have normal lives many of those
babies have maybe some some
developmental problems but it's not
severe when you have severe microcephaly
like a Down syndrome baby they need
support for the rest of their life and
so it's really important that we what
we're seeing now is that even some
babies that are born with small-sized
heads at birth are actually doing ok
they're doing well they're not having
long lasting effects but there's other
babies that have severe micro cific
severe small sizes which means they have
severe small-sized brains and they need
support and they're having also other
problems problems with their eyes
problems with their vision problems with
their growth problems with their balance
and it's really important that we have
the programs in place to support those
babies support those mums and dads and
those families and that's what's really
important so we're really worried about
this in countries where we're seeing an
increased number of microcephaly does
the program at the hospital or the
community are those programs in place to
support those mums and dads with a baby
that needs a lot of support and that
doesn't always happen we have a question
from Hawaii do you think that just like
the influenza the Zika virus can go
through with mutations since some cases
of Zika are different from another yeah
that's a great question because again
this is it's what's called an RNA virus
and we know that with all these these
RNA viruses they mutate they change a
million times a day does that mean
anything we don't really know it does it
does it make them more infectious does
it change the outcome in babies not
really but when we're monitoring this so
it's really important that we have we
have laboratories we have University
we have scientists that are monitoring
the Zika virus in many countries because
the big concern is that it's going to
nearly 60 countries now since 2007 it's
gone to nearly 45 countries in the last
12 months so it's going through that
cycle of mosquito to people mosquito to
people and every time it goes through
that cycle it has a chance to mutate and
it's really important that we stay on
top of this to monitor any mutations if
we find a mutation then we have to do
more research and understand what does
that mutation mean so again this is a
concern we had this was one of the
hypothesis this was one of the ideas
that was posed back in Brazil last year
in May 2015 when Brazil said hey we've
got increased cases of Zika and people
increased cases of microcephaly small
size but babies being born with small
heads we didn't know whether it was this
because of a mutation and we're not and
so we're still studying now and we can
do this what's called through genomic
sequencing we do a fingerprint of the
virus and we see whether the virus has
mutated and again we have to work out if
that mutation actually is going to cause
any problems and that's that's what
researchers do every day right now well
from King drew Thank You dr. McGregor
it's coming to the conclusion of our
presentation for today would you guys
like to say something
you want so nice also for Hawaii we
learned a lot
you're very welcome